Mark's lares he's got my respect because
he played hurt all the time he wouldn't
let mono bother him like Sam darn old is
Sam's gonna miss Monday night's game
against the Browns Sam Donaldson the
game right mark absolutely right come on
you can play through that okay well
anyway I was calling I was calling to
Detroit Arizona game and their head
coach or Detroit's head coach obviously
Matt Patricia rolls in on the little
cart you know because you had the
Achilles tendon we had that fix this
summer and I looked I took one look at
them ago you know I'd be playing with
that you realize I'd be playing with
that I don't want to hear about how
you're gonna you know stand on crutches
on the sideline just suck it up you
stand there and you know and look the
part you had all these surgeries but
like let's say if you have the flu are
you expected to play with the flu oh
yeah where you are okay yeah I mean
everybody has everybody at some point I
mean it's not like we're immune
everybody gets sick there babe everybody
place or everybody plays the flu you
know the bottom line is if you don't eat
it Wally PIPP you know the next guy
comes in to be placed Beauty takes your
job one of the things I love about the
NFL is the the just a whole meritocracy
of it you know like it doesn't matter in
baseball nowadays and you're a big
baseball guy Dan in baseball right now
you're managing your roster you're
managing your minor leagues based on
what you've already paid guys and
there's some guys that deserve the
chance to get there but they don't ever
get there because we don't want to give
that guy on opportunity because we've
got all these other guys we've paid
stuff in the NFL doesn't matter what
school you went to doesn't matter where
you came from if you can play you get
the opportunity to play that's just the
way it goes and guys understand that
guys are afraid not to play hurt guys
are afraid not to play sick because they
don't want somebody to come in and play
better than them take their jobs what do
you think of must-win situations in week
two I think the way the league is
constructed this is the beauty of it
this is why you I hear this all the time
about hey let's explain the playoff
rosters and let's go to 18 games and
let's you know I'm like I love
the fact that in week two you can have
your finger squarely matched on the
panic button because you understand the
value of each and every game and when it
comes down to the end of the season you
understand that a man that were nine and
seven and have we won this one game at
ten and six were a playoff team at nine
and seven we're not that's why I like
when I hear people say hey let's explain
expand the playoff rosters I'm like heck
no I want to expand anything I don't
want expand the seasons I want to expand
the rosters I don't want any of that
stuff because I like the value week in
and week out of having you know your
backs against the wall having these must
win situations if you will okay so is a
must-win situation for the Browns on
Monday night against the Jets I think I
think I look at the Browns it you know I
mean it's never really a must-win
situation but they got to play well like
they've got a show in the Browns you
know at one point you know Baker
Mayfield is like amen the hype is real
the hype is this I do that and then they
lose the game it's like everybody's
throwing us in the trash you know we're
gonna have this chip on our shoulder I'm
like it shut up just go out and actually
play like when I go to a steak
restaurant you know what I ordered a
damn I order a steak I don't order a
plate of sizzle like I don't want to
play don't bring me a plate this isn't
good boy does that sound great Oh smell
that sizzle mmm it doesn't fill you up
and the problem with the Browns is all
offseason look at all these moves we've
made with all these master we have look
at all the sizzle we have at some point
you got to drop a set and go out and
play and so I'm looking forward to
seeing if they can actually drop a set
or if the sizzle is more important if
we're in watches that were you know that
are worth more than most people make in
Cleveland you know or most people's
houses are worth in Cleveland if that's
more important than you to you then
actually going out and providing some
steak like I want to see if there's any
steak to Cleveland right now
talking to Marc solarath from Fox Sports
did you ever give a pep talk when you
were with the Broncos oh yeah yeah yeah
I called a meeting once Dan
we had lost I was out with a back injury
and I had surgery on my back in 97 so we
have lost yeah exactly I was out for 27
days with a back surgery yeah my I hung
upside down for four hours where they're
operating my back and took me 27 days to
get back I apologize you know maybe I
don't have the right to talk about
deafness anyhow anyhow so we had lost
several games in row well we didn't play
well you know and guys were guys were
showing up kind of and there's some guys
showing up late or two seconds before
the meeting starts and they're not you
know they're in their street clothes and
so I just called a meeting about two
things I was like one you show up late
to this football team like what you're
saying is that your time is more
valuable than my time that your family
is more valuable than my family and that
is garbage that is a recipe for losing
the other thing that I wanted to impress
upon that team was it's our team like
Mike Shanahan has never gone out made
one tackle right he's not going to throw
one block it's us were the ones that go
out and do it nobody nobody pays money
to come and watch the owner sit around
his ass off in the box
they come to watch the players play it
is our team we need to take ownership
and the way we've played is absolute
garbage is an affront to good football
and you see some of these things break
down and I think it doesn't matter what
number of player you are on the roster
if you're the first player or the 53rd
player if you see something that's wrong
I think it's your responsibility to
point out that it's wrong my dad used
tell me this all the time when I was
growing up Dan and I've always held on
to it
it's indelibly marked on me forever he
said there's no right way to do
something wrong and when I was a kid I
was trying to get over when I was a kid
I was trying to cut corners he would
always tell me that mark there's no
right way to do something wrong it's
either right or it's wrong and any time
you put yourself in front of your
teammates I'm sorry it's wrong if you
were the commissioner roger goodell what
would you do with the Antonio Brown
situation
ah you know you've got to let due
process take its course but I think the
best thing you could possibly do right
now and that's happening is it put them
on the commissioners exempt list he gets
paid right he's still part of the team
but we have to make sure I mean it is a
civil suit and I think one of the issues
it's it's a slippery slope damn because
the issues that that we have right now
is you know is how much guys get how
much time they lose and in a day and age
that we live in anybody can make a false
accusation anybody can do something and
get a lot of get a lot of run on Twitter
and on social media but if this is a
criminal case though mark would you if
these were criminal a criminal suit as
opposed to a civil suit would you have a
different opinion on Antonio Brown no I
my opinion is I still think you put them
on the commissioners exemplar santel and
so it runs its course I you know and now
I'm I'm a guy also that I think he's a
turd so that probably that probably you
know biases my opinion to some degree
just because of his antics in the way he
you know the way he goes about his
profession so I always you know I always
say just because you play a pro sport
doesn't make you a professional world
when it comes to treat your teammates
and the way you should approach the game
he certainly is nobody's professional if
he was your teammate though like I'm
sure you didn't get along with all your
teammates here and you probably had some
personalities you didn't like so how do
you handle something like you know these
Patriots you know they didn't sign up
for it
and now all of a sudden they're
answering for Antonio Brown here so what
do you do when you have a teammate that
you don't respect well you just try to
avoid the questions the problem is is
it's not just the questions from the
media you can avoid that you know one of
the things about the NFL locker room ban
is it's so compartmentalized but if you
laid out 12 photographs of all the 12
teams that I played for and said what
you could probably point to six guys
that I couldn't tell you what their
names are so there's a there's a
compartmentalization that goes on within
a locker room I go to my meeting you go
to your meeting sometimes we don't even
bump into each other you're
your side of the field on defensive
backs I'm on my side of the field as an
offensive lineman you don't ever really
interact so you can avoid the guy it's
not hard to avoid the guy within a
within the context of the facility was
with the meeting rooms and all that
stuff and you can avoid the media you
know when they come to ask you question
about it you can shut it down or as a
lot of guys do they just go hide in the
training room till the media has to
leave I mean that's what guys do
so the problem the true problem is your
mom's going to call you your wife's
gonna ask you a question your sister's
going to call you your buddies from
college you're going to call you you're
gonna go out to dinner with your bride
and the waiter is gonna ask you like
that's where you can't get away from
Antonia Brown he's like a fungus right
and there's no amount of tinactin
that'll get rid of the guy when's the
last time you hit somebody yeah that's
why I'm listening so much dude I am
freakin yoked it's like I guarantee I
can't bench 3/4 of the NFL right now I
am I mean I am I got a lot of I got a
lot of I guess I don't know that I could
pass the drug test damn but I am I am
would you to have taken anything to play
though would you have taken anything to
play oh yeah you know I looked at man my
ass would have been a pin cushion had
that been the only way I thought I could
play but you know I got in the NFL and
at that point drug testing was really
stringent and I found out when I got in
the NFL like I was a good player and I
was I've always been country strong so I
was like I didn't like I was like okay I
don't like I don't need it I'm there's
nobody any stronger than me in this
league so you ever try was that ever try
steroids yeah yeah when I was in college
I did for injury so I do and you know
what the problem with let me tell you a
problem with steroids is that is that
it's a synthetic it's a synthetic
strength so
like people think you just take them and
you get strong you still have to work
incredibly hard but as soon as you get
off the stuff you start to get weak
again when I tore my ACL I was told by
some of the older guys to take them I
tried them and I didn't like the I
didn't like the up and down I didn't
like it so I just got I just got off and
I never used them ever I never used them
ever late in my college career or
throughout my professional career yeah I
am a guy who played in the NFL at a high
level and he said you know you know this
is what I think about steroids they work
he got he got busted once in his career
for using but he said you know the
reason why guys want to try it is they
work and he was coming back from an
injury as well right there's no there's
no question but again like I said you
get like it's synthetic so that strength
you gain you lose just as I think I
think the reason guys the reason guys
can't get off dan once once they start
is because there's a psychological
aspect of that drug you know that people
don't realize because that they strength
gains or like when you're working hard
the strength gains are obedient but the
strength losses are immediate to when
you get off and so they get
psychologically addicted to that feeling
and like I said like I said I came off
an ACL and I was struggling and I didn't
like the I didn't like the up-and-down
part not that it didn't affect me like
it didn't affect me like aggressiveness
or anything like that I just didn't like
the fact you know that once I got off I
got weak again I was like I'd rather
just maintain my strength level which I
was always able to do so but again you
know you're doing dumb and you try
something and uh not that it's not
regrettable I don't you know whatever it
I didn't like it I never ever used
anything illegal during the course of my
NFL career but again you know I was on
all kinds of I mean I did toradol I did
anti-inflammatories hell I to rub the
dog turd on it I thought that made you
feel better so DMSO you
name it you know I tried it because I
want to line up every weekend play that
was my goal
who's the strongest defensive lineman
you went against probably Luther Ellis
you remember Luther Ellis from the Lions
yeah Lions and oh I got another one the
two guys John Pirela
from the Chargers back in the day have
you noticed I don't know about you but I
can't even say SD anymore like the city
it's one of the greatest cities in the
world and I can't even say the name
anymore like I get I go Padres
I go Chargers the first time I was
broadcasting I had the Chargers and I
use the SD at least three or four times
five times during the broadcast you know
it's old habits die hard
now I feel like it's taboo like it's you
know like it's eat a turd sandwich and
it's one of the most beautiful places in
the whole world and I can't even say the
name anymore like they've ruined me this
whole move to Los Angeles the Carson has
it's ruined to me what is wrong with you
dirty what happened to you know you need
to hit somebody you need to hit somebody
what's what's your game this weekend I
am Chicago at Denver so I got a little
home game yeah thanks thanks yeah
well yeah one don't hit dick Stockton's
all right if you're gonna hit somebody
do not hit dick I would never ever hit
dick stop it you can't just end it with
just dick you're right you're right
right my bad my bad did this all very
ever get you with that did he get you
with the the Laker GM Mitch Kupchak yeah
let me say this it's great to hear your
voice it's great to catch up with you
and for those who don't know when we
work together at ESP and all those years
ago
you were very kind and generous with
your time and I as a young broadcaster
coming in who didn't know anything
you're always good to me so thank you
Dan I appreciate you well hopefully you
still have a job after this appearance
we always Maggie Marc that's Marc's
laris Fox NFL analyst for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]